welcome to this episode of uxd where
we're going to talk about what context
is and why it's critical to
understanding how people use technology
and how it affects their their
expectations from this technology
I'm your host Nazmul Idris a developer
advocate passionate about design and
mobile and I have a very special guest
with me on the show today
accessible I'm Paul saxman also
developer advocate and I love everything
about maps location-based apps and
likewise design excellent you're at the
right show there are a few main elements
of context time goal location and
attitude a user's context is driven by
the amount of time a user has to
accomplish a goal the tasks that the
user needs to perform to accomplish this
goal using a variety of different
devices and applications where the user
is physically located are they at home
at work at an airport what what the user
state of mind is and are they happy sad
stressed seeking company or wanting to
be alone all these things put together
drive how people choose the devices they
use and it also effects their
expectations from applications on these
devices users have an expectation from
technology and oftentimes this
expectation is not met by current
products sometimes this dissonance is a
result of creators of these products not
understanding how small changes and
elements of context have huge impacts on
user expectations so to deliver a great
experience you have to ensure that your
app meets the users expectations on
specific devices for specific contexts
to highlight the interplay between
context device selection and user
expectations we will give you some
examples of common scenarios that people
encounter in their daily lives and how
these situations affect their
interaction with different devices that
they used to perform various tasks so
let's say you're at home sitting in your
living room watching Walking Dead your
favorite show yeah exactly
on your TV and you see an exotic
location like Atlanta and you want to do
some research on vacation spots in that
area during the commercial break you
might pick up your tablet or laptop and
use your favorite travel app to find
vacation destinations
Atlanta now since you're at home in a
relaxed environment and are performing a
task that's not really urgent you're
simultaneously watching TV and using
your laptop or tablet to do some
research you're probably also checking
your email and social media on your
smartphone people who are distracted or
let's say you're at an airport and
you're checking in for your flight you
might want your boarding pass
information what gate to go to and
real-time flight status updates all on
your smart phone since you're an airport
in a stressful environment and are
performing many tasks that require that
are really urgent
you're intermittently interacting with
your smartphone and probably not your
laptop or your tablet even though your
attention is split amongst doing
different things the shorts the short
bursts of interaction that you do have
with your smartphone are really intense
in this in this context or let's say
you're on the go you get hungry you
might want to find a place to eat nearby
that meets your dietary preferences and
maybe even get recommendations from
people you trust all in your smartphone
since you're out and need to get some
food very soon you're not really in the
mood to do in-depth research on places
to eat or wait around to make
reservations you're not really doing any
researching or planning instead you just
want to find the best possible place to
eat nearby on your smartphone we'll head
it over to you then so back to this
example of traveling to Atlanta all you
need to do some research plan the trip
and then actually make the journey there
possibly using a variety of devices so
with you as a user in this example let's
look in detail of what context is and
how it impacts the user expectations and
their device selection if you're not in
a rush and you have time to do planning
and research you would probably use a
laptop or tablet to start these tasks
but not necessarily complete them you
might choose to continue these tasks on
different devices at a later time or you
might choose to restart the process on
the same device the key here is that the
user has a lot of time in their hand to
complete their task so it's easy for
them to switch between devices however
data in the new multi-screen world study
published by Google shows that people
tend to use laptops and tablets over
smartphones for research or planning
tasks likely because of the largest
screens and richer input that's not to
say you can ignore smartphones of
thirty-four percent of people will
generally reach for the devices closest
to them so always keep smartphones in
mind when building apps because although
it's not the ideal device for research
tasks your user might reach for them out
of convenience I do that all the time
likewise if you're not going to travel
soon in a matter of weeks then you would
probably want to book your flights in
hotel this is going from research to
planning again you might use a tablet to
start these planning tasks and complete
them on a laptop or vice versa people do
tend to use laptops over tablets for
productivity tasks such as booking the
flight hotel a rental car but it's not
uncommon for people to use tablets for
augmenting or wrapping up planning that
makes sense on the day of your travel
you might want to get your boarding pass
get a taxi to the airport you get
terminal and flight updates that type of
thing these are all types of tacet that
people tend to do on their smartphones
it's not likely that you want to pull
out your laptop or tablet well you know
picking up your boarding pass or finding
your way to the terminal also you'd
probably expect to use your smartphone
to retrieve information you need when
you need it ideally your smartphone and
making important information available
automatically without even asking just
like Google now when things are urgent
and you have lots of tasks to do that
our time-sensitive people tend to use
their smartphones as a way to execute
tasks rather than research or plan also
in these situations people don't have
much patience for hiccups in the user
experience and is best to provide a
solid and minimal experience that allows
the user to do what they want quickly
and smoothly as we saw in the time
examples a task can be dependent on both
time and location actually most of the
aspects of context are interrelated
somehow however each can have some
independent influence and how you build
an app so to ensure that you're covering
all possible user scenarios you should
try to consider each variable
independently so continuing with the
Atlanta example let's look what happens
when we focus on the task aspect of
context you'd likely perform the
following tasks possibly independently
in order to accomplish your goal of
traveling to Atlanta
again travel research is something that
you'd probably start weeks before
actually traveling during the research
phase you would likely try to figure out
what neighborhood you want to stay in
well Atlanta and also check out hotels
the book for research people's
expectations of apps and devices that
content consumption should be painless
and the amount of user input is minimal
in other words for supporting research
and apps should be optimized for content
consumption but not necessarily content
creation and again you might want to
switch back and forth between these
devices to accomplish this tasks so be
sure to keep user entered data like
starred hotels or planning them places
to visit on the servers so that it can
be available between sessions on
different devices planning is something
that you might want to do a week or two
before traveling planning tasks for
travel include booking flights hotels
rental cars your expectations of an app
use for planning would likely be that
content creation should be effortless
since you might have to input a lot of
data so apps optimize planning should
allow for easy data entry and also easy
content consumption and again you might
switch back and forth between these
devices to accomplish this task you
might want to retrieve critical data a
few days before traveling but you most
likely need access to critical data the
day of traveling listening includes
information like flight status hotel
reservations and boarding passes and
other information as you move from one
transit to a former transit to another
until you reach your destination since
you're on the go people would use a
smartphone to accomplish all these tasks
it's highly unlikely that you would do
any of these tasks on tablets or laptops
you're expecting expectations of apps
that you're using as smartphones are
quite stringent you would want single
headed navigation minimal interaction
with the apps to get your content and
you would want the app to actually
proactively notify you of things via
notifications when critical information
that impacts your itinerary changes what
you're not expecting is a lot of content
consumption or creation so the content
has to be presented in a way that you
can consume in it quick quickly without
much attention your interactions with
advice is bursty short and intense we
definitely do more episodes on that
- pretty heavy topic indeed yeah
location tasks and time are very very
critical points yes and finally let's
look at what happens when we focus on
location aspect of context depending on
what your physical location is what
tasks you would need to perform and the
time you had to perform them changes you
might perform research and planning a
test run at home on your sofa or at a
desk your time frame for getting these
tasks completed can vary from many weeks
to research at a few weeks for planning
your expectations from apps that you're
using is that you should have a
signed-in experience where they allow
you to seamlessly move between devices
another expectation you have is that
content consumption should be easy for
research tasks and some content creation
should be easy for planning tasks but
definitely gonna do a show on designed
an experience that's a whole other show
in its heaven you might be for retrieval
tasks when you're on the go and your
time frame for getting these tasks
completed can vary from urgent or right
now to some time this week
user research data and the study
suggests that people use smartphones
when the urgency is high and they're on
the go so you have an expectation from
apps that you're using that you should
be aware of current location and be able
to deliver information to you an
uncluttered manner so you don't have to
spend a lot of attention on the device
another expectation is that you get
notifications of important things that
will impact your itinerary but you don't
want to be overwhelmed with too many
notifications since you're going to be
doing other things while interacting
with your smartphone in intense bursts
it's like the constant interplay between
machine narcissism and self-awareness
for the application so again topics for
other shows very cool now let's take a
look at what happens when we focus on
the social aspect of context so you've
talked a lot about how time tasks and
location has an impact on what people
expect and what we're gonna show you is
that those three things come together
and they also drive what you're
expecting out of your applications or
experiences and devices from a social
perspective so when you're at home at
work you might want to perform some
research tasks when you have a lot of
time on your hands in this scenario you
might want to collaborate with coworkers
if the trip to Atlanta is a business
or you want one or with family members
if it's a personal trip if you're
performing some planning tasks and have
less time on your hands than you do for
research then you might want to share
your itinerary with co-workers or family
and find out what restaurants for
example people you know would recommend
in Atlanta and then actually make some
reservations so people tend to use a
tablet or laptop when doing this sort of
collaboration when your expectations
from applications you're using on these
devices are that it should be easy to
consume lots of content and but do a
little bit of content creation but the
collaboration aspect is part of content
creation and the sharing of information
is part of creation and consumption so
basically you should be able to do a
little bit of both now when you're on
the go you might want to perform some
retrieval tasks and many of these tasks
might be urgent in this scenario you
might just want to get visibility into
others activities for example you might
want to get commute updates and see when
your co-workers or family members have
arrived at their destination or where
they are in transit and so on that'd be
really cool at the multi-screen world
report suggests that people use
smartphones when doing this which made
sense however the other people in this
scenario that is your co-workers or
family members or friends might be using
tablets or laptops or smartphones so
managing expectations around social
expectations is really complicated and
there are so many constituents that you
have to keep in mind when doing this
Google now is a great example so what if
you do if you turn on commute sharing it
will notify people in the circles that
you've chosen to actually get these
updates without you actually having to
do anything on your smartphone they get
notifications and you just go about your
day finally let's look at what happens
when we focus on the mood aspect of
context where you are how much time you
have and what tasks you need to perform
have a big impact on your mood or
attitude when performing these tasks and
again this drives your expectations in a
big way I know this is complicated but
it's complicated because it is complex
it's a crazy interplay yeah exactly so
every little thing is related to
everything else so if you're at home or
at work and doing research tasks with
lots of time to complete them
then you might be in a relaxed mood you
might be lazy and open to collaboration
this drives the expectations that you
have around what social experience you
want from the application and the device
that you're using and it also determines
how eager you are to select the right
device for the task for example you
might just use whatever is closest to
you rather than getting to the right
device the most appropriate one for the
task at hand so you might use a
smartphone that's close by instead of
picking up a laptop which might be and
in the next room to do heavy content
consumption or even content creation
however since you're more relaxed in
this context you are more willing to put
up with the more constrained form factor
now if you increase the urgency in this
scenario then your motivation to
actually get the appropriate device for
the task and goes way up
human beings are complicated now imagine
if you're on the go the big change that
you have is in your mood is that you're
more you might be more stressed simply
because there are time constraints
there's a lot of stimulus from your
external environment you could be in an
unfamiliar place so already your
cognitive load is higher from simply
being outside and not being in a relaxed
environment like your home assuming your
home is a relaxed environment retrieval
tasks that you might want to perform
might be quite urgent and this adds to
your stress and this drives your
expectation from the smartphone and the
apps that you're using on them they need
to be accurate aware of where you are
and give you updates that you need in
real time and the battery can be drained
either and the location readings should
be accurate so even though you might be
using the same application and device in
your living room by simply changing your
mood from relaxed to stress it greatly
changes the expectations you have from
that particular application advice so we
encourage you to read this wonderful
research study titled the new
multi-screen world that has a lot of
information that provides more insights
into how people use technology the
report shows us that people have certain
expectations from tablets and laptops
however on smartphones they expect
a little bit of everything so keep this
notion of context in mind when you
create your application experiences on
multiple devices there are a lot of
constraints that should be you should be
mindful off and we've covered some of
them in this episode and we'll do more
episodes to cover their to cover them in
great detail and know that if you
violate these constraints then you're
more likely to live to deliver a bad
user experience
I want to thank Paul again for being on
the show thank you so much for watching
and see you next time